joining me now here prior to monday
night football right here on westwood
one as the bears taking on the
pittsburgh steelers it is time for a guy
who knows all about playing in big prime
time games from back in his collegiate
days now a professional quarterback
starting for the chicago bears justin
fields how are you justin i'm doing good
how are you i'm doing better for talking
to you um how are you looking forward to
this
monday night under the lights game for
you look at this
you know i think everybody is you know
we've been working hard at practice this
week so we're just excited that we get
another opportunity to uh uh play this
this upcoming monday and how do you feel
your first several starts in the league
is gone how do you feel um i feel like
you know of course we could have had
some some different outcomes but you
know i think every game i'm trying to
improve and i'm learning more and more
each and every day so i'm just going to
continue to get better and what is that
that you're learning specifically i just
know just a bunch of stuff you know how
the game is played
just you know the ins and outs of nfl
football and you know how how to put
jobs together and stuff like that so um
the game is much different than college
but i think you know the more and more i
play the more and more i'll get used to
it you should see those little defensive
stuff okay let me let me try and nail
you down on a specific thing um what are
you better at right now
going into this week nine finale against
the steelers than you were
on that day in cleveland for instance uh
i think instead of trying to push the
ball downfield you know when it's not
there i'm quicker to get my check down
so
really just taking what the defense
gives me rather than you know pushing
the ball down field and
uh not not forcing anything okay and so
that's just your general that's your
general sense of trying to force going
out there is that what your
default is that's your default is trying
to go out there and make the big play
justin
uh what do you mean my defaults that's
what your general sense that you're
under center like i'm gonna make the big
play right here that's your general
sense
coming in to the league
i mean not not necessarily um you know
i don't i don't think that's the case uh
but in the league you definitely check
the ball out more than you do in college
so uh that's that's one big difference
okay and uh what about the speed of the
game i hear so much in my years of
covering the nfl for somebody who's
coming in from the collegiate level um
in his rookie season that the speed of
the game is something that
yeah i have to get adjusted to i don't
know if you've heard me get asked this
question but
i'm probably the only one that will not
answer this question just because i get
so much stuff for it so i'm not going to
answer any questions regarding the speed
of the game but that's all right you
know it's of course i i have not heard
you being asked honestly i'm coming into
this fresh i mean i've just gotten so
much so much crap from everybody and all
the social media and stuff i'll just
stay away i just don't answer that
question for the rest of my career i'm
never gonna answer that question again
so
well you've got speed yourself i mean
you can utilize that right i mean how
how much of
your your um
starting
or do you go um into a play
wondering about at what point do you
have to bail and things like that i mean
what about that concept just kind of a
reaction you know i'm not going into the
startup replay thinking that i'm going
to have to scramble so of course i'm
looking to pass first and then you know
if that internal clock in your head goes
off or you know your guys are on opened
out field or you sense pressure on you
then of course you have to escape your
pocket and be able to make a play okay
justin fields here prior to monday night
football taking on the pittsburgh
steelers do you read your mentions on
social media i would counsel you against
that mine's a dumpster fire right now
justin personally you know i mean no
it's just you know i think it was after
our second preseason game i think uh no
it was actually after the first one
a reporter asked me if the speed of the
game how was that and i said you know it
was slower than i expected it to be just
because you know i was going up against
our starting defense at the time so
you know i was going up against you know
a starting nfl defense i practice every
day so you know i said it was slower
than i expected it to be and of course
everybody took it out of proportion
saying or the next game we played the
bills and of course i i missed the uh
blitzer off the edge and
my helmet flew off or whatever and then
everybody just started coming from my
head talking about i thought this uh the
speed of the game was slowness and that
so
yeah um
that's that's pretty much okay here's
what you should do you should again just
because i try to make people who who say
yes to an interview with me better than
when i just found them what you should
do is you should wait for that question
since obviously you get it clearly a lot
wait for it to come from somebody from
let's just say the southeast conference
part of the united states and say of
course the game's not slow for me i'm
from the big ten say that
and see how that one flies what do you
think i think that would be a good
answer
they might refer back to the national
championship so that night might not be
a good answer i don't know
i mean in all honesty so um now that
you're um
you know now in the month of november
and starting several games in the nfl
what would you say to i'm sure again if
you're seeing out there on social media
the questions that
that you need to be because you're
beaten up quite a bit sometimes in some
games you've suffered a lot of sacks
that you are
in danger of regressing
because you're taking a beating in the
pocket in some games how would you
respond to that justin
um
i mean of course there's definitely a
possibility there but i think
the situation that i'm in i think that
it you know it varies from person to
person you know somebody that you know
isn't confident in themselves that you
know that's playing the game of football
if they're struggling at first and they
might take a step back and question
their ability to make plays on the field
if you know things aren't going so well
the first few games so
i just think it varies from person to
person but you know if you're fully
confident in yourself and fully
convicted that
you're made to be here and you know
you're you were put in the situation for
a reason and that you were you know
built for the moment then i don't think
that you're going to regress at all it's
just
a fact that you know of course you've
got to get
better with your
protections and your you know your your
alignment has to be to protect so i
think that's that but i mean that's
that's definitely a good question
because um
you know i think in some cases you know
guys can regress or lose confidence in
their ability to you know play and uh
make plays out there on the field but so
you're aware uh i mentioned
in this conversation came up i pointed
out that after you were sacked nine
times
by the browns in your first career start
you won the next week
so where's the regression there you know
what i mean like yeah for sure i mean
you know uh in the nfl there's gonna be
games where you know that don't you go
your way and it's all about how you
respond to it i mean that's essentially
life you know in life they're gonna be
tough times and you know you can either
you know face the fact or
uh run away from it so um
like i said in you know i think we
played the uh patriots i mean i'm gonna
continue to work no matter what the
outcome is and um um just continue to
get better so okay so justin fields few
minutes left with the bears quarterback
prior to monday night football here on
westwood one against the pittsburgh
steelers so when you were named i love
this i want to hear more about this
because it it it kind of also lets
people in on who your support group is
in your first season in the nfl true
story then that you're named the
starting quarterback by your coach matt
neggie and your folks wanted to go out
to dinner and you said no right yeah
right
it was just
yeah it is it was just you know the the
timing of it if it was later in the week
you know maybe a friday or saturday i
would have gone but you know it was a it
was a tuesday or or wednesday i think so
i mean we're just starting a game plan
for you know the uh
i think i think it was the
the promise right yeah no it was after
the brownstone
uh raiders that week so sure um yeah i
mean just just that point in time you
know i was just trying to of course you
know make sure i got the game planned
down and and studies our plays and stuff
like that when when later in the week
you know when you pretty much have the
game plan down you pretty much know what
their uh their tendencies are on defense
you know you can kind of have it but i
was just trying to you know just just
get that down and kind of kind of get
the play book down and just just stay in
my same routine because you know my
parents would come up every week they
were just there for that
okay i was about to ask so if they're in
town or who's your support team who do
you lean on during this yeah
during this time my parents for sure my
dad you know he's my best friend i can
tell him anything so um my parents you
know they've been there from the start
uh i think
combined they've missed maybe one
football game so i mean they've they've
been at every game you know they used to
take me from you know quarterback lesson
to baseball practices to all of that
back in the day so i mean i have a great
support system for my family
okay and then just uh who else anybody
football was anybody that uh from your
past that you
that you reach out to counsel lean on
pick brains anything for you justin i
talked to cam uh maybe i think it was
last week so uh he had a few good things
to say and um
stuff like that so that's one mentor you
know that i can hit up whenever and you
know he can always give me some good
advice this is what does he tell can
can you give me a little nugget like
what is cam newton telling you i mean
obviously he knows
the game very well and maybe your game
in particular so
i think you know the main thing i took
out of the conversation with him or one
of the main points he was telling me is
just don't lose out of who you are you
know i mean it was kind of it's kind of
going to the point of uh you know can
quarterbacks regress after their start
but you know uh it's just don't forget
who you are uh you know from
a kid growing up to high school to
college i mean i've always been you know
uh
one of the most talented on the field so
it's just you know don't lose that
confidence that you're one of the best
players on the field and just play like
it and um you know the more confident
you are the the better you'll play and
um it's just that simple so that's
definitely uh one of the uh things that
he told me it's gonna be pretty cool for
you that you can reach out to cam newton
of all people i mean i mean mvp in this
league and
entertaining and iconic he definitely
was that after he said that at his
combine yeah it's gonna be pretty cool
for you yeah uh i've i've known cam
since a a junior in high school so we
have a pretty good relationship
all right so with the last one for your
challenge against the steelers what
you've seen so far on film and what
you're going to be ready for under the
monday night lights justin fields you
know uh most of their players has been
in the system for a long time
and of course you know they they know
the ins and out i think they do a good
job of switching up their coverages
doing a good job disguising and you know
their front seven uh this is pretty good
you know they're d line with tj cameron
hayward so uh it's going to be a
challenge for us but you know we're just
excited and you know ready for this
opportunity so can't wait justin fields
thanks for doing this greatly appreciate
it have a blast in your first monday
night game of your career may it be the
first of many for you sir appreciate you
have a good time you got it that's
justin fields getting ready to take on
the pittsburgh steelers on monday night
football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here